tengo la función fx igual a x al
cuadrado y lo que me interesa es
determinar el área que queda por debajo
de la curva
fx y por encima del eje x entre los
puntos 1 y 4 así que déjame poner aquí
los ejes el eje x el eje i y aquí voy a
poner la gráfica de la función la voy a
poner en color blanco y quedaría como
una parábola nada más voy a pintar lo
que sucede aquí en el primer cuadrante
claro también podríamos pintar acá lo
del segundo cuadrante pero eso no nos va
a interesar ahorita va y los puntos que
nos interesan aquí en un extremo tenemos
a el punto 1 y el otro que nos intereses
acá en el punto 4 entonces queremos
determinar queremos determinar el área
el área de esta región de acá sale
déjame lo pinto
acá en se interpretarían más para arriba
y queremos determinar el área de esta
región
sin embargo ahorita yo ya estoy cansado
de las aproximaciones y lo que quiero es
dar el área exacta bueno afortunadamente
ya platicamos de cómo hacerlo verdad
para para denotar esta área de acá lo
que tenemos que hacer es escribir una
integral tenemos que escribir la
integral la integral de a a b pero aquí
a es un ip es 4 entonces sería la
integral de 1 a 4 de fx de x y la forma
en la cual pensábamos esta anotación
bueno al menos la forma en la cual yo lo
pienso es que nos está diciendo que
sumemos una infinidad de áreas de
rectángulo este de x es el ancho de cada
rectángulo que es un rectángulo
infinitamente flaco entonces déjame
poner algunos ejemplos de rectángulos
por acá arriba digo no van a quedar
infinitamente flacos pero es para
mostrar la idea entonces ahí tendríamos
algunos rectángulos y lo que va haciendo
esta cosa es sumar las áreas de todos
estos un área otra área otra área y esto
nos recuerda muchísimo a las
aproximaciones con rectángulos porque
justo esta definición de integral de
riman venía de aproximaciones con
rectángulos verdad de sumas de riman
entonces el ancho es de x y el alto el
alto de cada uno de los rectángulos es f
x así aquí estamos sumando una infinidad
de áreas
por eso la el signo de integral se
parece como a una s es una s de sumar y
es una suma infinita de áreas de
rectángulos infinitamente flacos vale
bueno por así decirlo hasta ahorita
hemos usado pues pura notación verdad
esta es la expresión que denota el área
pero todavía no la hemos calculado para
eso vamos a utilizar el segundo teorema
fundamental del cálculo así que déjame
escribirlo por acá para acordarnos que
decía y básicamente nos decía lo
siguiente que si f x era la derivada de
otra función
efe mayúscula lo pongo
efe de x es derivada de derivada de f
mayúscula de x o bien también podríamos
escribirlo como que fx es una anti
derivada una anti derivada
de fx de f de x entonces podemos
determinar esta área como ya platicamos
en el vídeo pasado podemos determinar el
área que queremos como efe de 4 efe
mayúscula la anti derivada en el extremo
superior
- efe de 1 - f1 evaluada en el extremo
inferior bueno pues vamos a hacer esto
para el caso que tenemos aquí en
concreto que es f x igual x al cuadrado
vamos a ver que nos queda entonces
tendríamos que encontrar la integral de
1 a 4 de x cuadrada de x y para esto lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar una anti derivada para x
cuadrada déjame escribirlo por acá o sea
así y fx es igual a x al cuadrado
y tal cuadrado entonces quién sería f
mayúscula de x quién sería una anti
derivada
bueno pues acordándonos de cómo se
deriva x a alguna potencia entera pues
vamos a ver qué pasa digamos derivando x
q va entonces recordando las reglas y
tomamos la derivada con respecto a x de
x al cubo de x al cubo pues el 3 baja
multiplicando nos quedaría 3 x x al
cuadrado y esto se parece mucho a lo que
queremos sólo que aquí hay un 3
hay un 3 que nos está estorbando que
hacemos para quitarlo pues dividimos
entre 3 de ambos lados dividimos entre 3
acá
dividimos entre 3 acá este 3 se va con
este 3 va y entonces aquí ya tenemos que
un tercio de la derivada es x cuadrada o
bien también podemos pensarlo como que
la derivada con respecto a x de de x al
cubo
y entre 3 entre 3 es igual a x cuadrado
si puedes realizar la derivada 3 bajas
se cancela con el 3 y el exponente pasa
de ser 3 hacer 2 así que esto en efecto
es x al cuadrado entonces x al cubo
entre 3 es una anti derivada para x
cuadrada eso está súper bueno entonces
esto es igual a y fíjate aquí se utilice
una nota se utiliza esta anotación aquí
ponemos la anti derivada entre 3 y aquí
se ponemos los numeritos en donde hay
que evaluar entonces arriba es 4 y abajo
es un algunas personas ponen además aquí
una barra vertical si ahorita yo lo voy
a dejar así porque se entiende del
contexto que estamos haciendo así que
vamos a realizar esta evaluación para
ver cuánto nos queda entonces esto de
aquí es igual a entonces 4 al cubo 4x4
es 16 por 4 64 así que aquí nos
quedarían déjame déjame ser más claro
para ver a ver voy a utilizar el color
azul del extremo de 4 entonces nos
quedaría 4 al cuadrado
y perdona el cubo que 64 dividido entre
3 y a eso tenemos que restar mira éste
64 tercios corresponde a estoy acá y a
eso tenemos que restar la anti derivada
que encontramos evaluada en 1 entonces
hay que restar
1 / 3 verdad 1 al cubo es uno entre tres
tercios muy bien ya nada más hay que
hacer las cuentas esto de aquí queda
fácil verdad 64 entre 3 - 1 entre 3 64
menos 163
y todo exterior y afortunadamente
podemos simplificar un poco porque 63
dividido entre 3 es igual a 20 121 muy
bien entonces con esto ya determinamos
el área así que bueno no importa qué
unidades teníamos acá abajo el área que
queda por debajo de x cuadrada de 1 a 4
y por arriba del eje x que es 21
unidades cuadradas